bom dia a todos e todas é um grande
prazer estar aqui pela segunda vez e o
tema desta oportunidade é muito
importante
a visão uma visão do lado feminino da
mulher é eu trabalho na vara da infância
e juventude que cuida da parte protetiva
da infância na cidade de são paulo tem
várias protetiva daquelas crianças que
estão em estado de abandono e tem uma
vara mais de uma vara e cuida da questão
infracional
a equipe é formada por aproximadamente
30 pessoas sendo 99% 99 mulheres
portanto o tema feminino é muito
presente nessa temática da questão da
infância e aqui eu vou trazer a questão
da infância sob outro enfoque
outro enfoque que a questão da mãe que
dá à luz a essas crianças
ainda que nosso trabalho seja muitas
vezes de socorrer a criança está numa
situação de vulnerabilidade e defender
os interesses dela é contrário ao
interesse da mãe
o tema que vou trazer hoje aqui é de uma
questão de um invisível feminino que a
mulher do cárcere
a mulher encarcerada à mulher em
situação prisional no brasil que sofre
muitíssimo e muitíssimo mais do que
sofre um homem preso
todos sabem se não o conhecimento
técnico mas por ouvir dizer lê nos
jornais a situação terrível tenebrosa
que são as masmorras são nas prisões
brasileiras para os homens
nunca se ouviu falar muito da situação
da mulher na prisão
quem tiver interesse pelo tema procure
uma pesquisa que existe no ministério da
justiça que se chama dar a dar à luz na
sombra pesquisa muita gente p filipéia
no brasil todo sobre a condição da
mulher né dentro da prisão
vou falar rapidamente sobre isso mas eu
achei oportuno como elas são invisíveis
como elas não têm voz e achou por bem
fazer mais para vocês um pequeno vídeo
produzido através de fotografias feitas
em duas penitenciárias uma brasileira
três penitenciárias uma brasileira
duas brasileiras uma das mães
encarceradas com seus bebês fotos de
empresas
em bebês e algumas fotos de uma
penitenciária em el salvador
chama-se penitenciária do pango onde
existe um acordo e mulheres presas
observem algumas fotos que não há grades
para essas mulheres a uma tela como tela
de galinheiro e as mulheres ficam
contidas ali ea maioria com seus filhos
que moram com ela essa situação
socioeconômica da dell salvador é
precaríssima quase metade da população é
presa no conto de crimes de tráfico e as
crianças moram dentro da prisão
então vou passar esse filme primeiro
como forma de sensibilização espero que
vocês não se comunica
o abstrato abre ação e o céu e tudo que
nasce a rebel tudo quebrou tudo fica
tudo tremeram
o evento faro como a anatel
é tenho o mar de um carro às vezes
necessária não só por risco
o rebento área é a mídia
a ai meus dados
são essas as fotos que eu acho
importante mostrar a elas autorizaram o
uso dessas fotos para esse fim
para que ela tivesse a possibilidade de
serem vistas e conhecidas como pessoas
humanas que estão nessa condição com o
foco pode mudar segundo a veja a
situação da mulher na prisão é muito
grave em dez anos nós temos um aumento
de 250% das prisões em 2000
seriam em torno de 10.000 dez mil
mulheres em 2012 o último censo mais 35
mil mulheres hoje muito mais que 35 mil
mulheres a maioria é negra ou parda
jovens quase todas todas com baixa renda
e baixa escolaridade e com as questão de
vulnerabilidade social muito semelhante
antes de entrar na prisão
a questão que se coloca é esse excesso
de prisão para mulheres
85% das presas hoje cometeram delitos
sem violência e contra o patrimônio ou
chamado delito que o microtráfico lá são
elas fazem bico no tráfico ou são presas
quando levam para seus maridos e
companheiros na prisão um pouco de droga
a situação é muito triste da mulher
presa brasileira porque ela vive uma
situação muito mais precária em termos
de garantias de direitos uma vez presa
ela perde apenas a liberdade de ir e vir
todavia mulher não tem direito a um
exame papanicolau a vacinas recentemente
coisa de até cinco anos é que se permite
o uso do sus para essas mulheres uma
conquista de longa luta dos movimentos
feministas e feminino dentro das prisões
e nós temos a questão da mãe dentro da
prisão
se a mulher invisível a mulher mãe é
mais visível
o brasil ainda não reúne condições de
atender os direitos dessa mãe de termos
penitenciárias com espaço adequado com
condição adequada para uma gestante ou
mesmo para uma mãe com o bebê
a lei brasileira diz que no mínimo o
filho deverá ficar seis meses com a mãe
no mínimo
todavia esse mínimo é o máximo então que
realidade nós temos mães que dão à luz
na prisão
como vocês já viram algumas inclusive
são levadas para o parto e hospitais
públicos algemadas né
houve alguns fatos que foram noticiados
mais e quase corriqueiro como se a
mulher merece uma segunda condição é
você está aqui que você é bandida e você
merece mais punição porque por cima está
grávida nem parece que a mensagem que se
quer passar essa
e essa criança nascendo permanece com
essa mãe e essa pesquisa que eu
mencionei é muito interessante porque
traz um dado muito bom de penitenciárias
consideradas boas mas que não admitem
para essa mãe nenhuma forma de autonomia
no exercício da maternidade
a comida que a criança tem que comer é o
que a prisão determina a forma de
educação de um bebê ou também a
exposição da mãe a uma hiper maternidade
já que ela teve o filho dentro da prisão
ela vai ficar 24 horas com esse filho
ou seja ela não pode mais trabalhar
dentro da prisão se está trabalhando
ela não pode estudar dentro da prisão se
ela estava estudando e essas duas coisas
estudar ou trabalhar permite a remissão
da pena então ela sofre um prejuízo por
ser mãe dentro da prisão
e aos seis meses sem nenhum preparo sem
nenhuma condição preparatória essa
criança retirada dessa mãe né então o
vínculo que ele pedalou risada durante
seis meses a amamentação o contato
diário é rompido sem nenhuma preparação
e qual é o destino dessa criança
as duas hipóteses se a uma família e
essa família vai receber essa criança
senão essa família essa criança vai para
um estudo de uma instituição de
acolhimento e aí nós entramos em cena
com o nosso trabalho que é cuidar dessa
criança e cuidar até quando para sempre
esperando que a mãe cumpra a pena que
pode ser seis sete oito anos
o esperado que essa mãe saia da cadeia e
depois consiga imediatamente se colocar
em uma situação de normalidade social
para poder acolher esse filho já então
sem vínculo talvez já então sem relação
com esse filho
muitas vezes a criança e levado à
instituição e é durante ou após uma
avaliação é feita uma ação e destituição
do poder familiar dessa mãe e esta
criança que também têm direito também é
um sujeito de direito tem que ser levada
para uma família substituta através da
adoção
então é um drama que não se não tem fim
para essa mulher
as penitenciárias que tem duas outras no
brasil que mantém mais de um tempo
mantém a criança também empresa com a
mãe ea onde fica o direito dessa criança
de ter uma vida normal a despeito de até
morar na prisão com a mãe né ao relato
de uma criança que nunca na bahia que
nunca tinha visto o céu à noite em que
ela morava dentro da cadeia com a mãe há
cinco horas tem a recolha fecham se as
pessoas dentro das celas
portanto a criança sempre entrava na
cela 5 horas da manhã
nunca tinha visto o céu à noite com
cinco anos de vida
então nós temos uma situação bastante
restrita absolutamente descumpridora
direitos básicos da mãe dentro das
prisões
também temos a questão da das visitas
íntimas que foi uma conquista para as
mulheres presas abenza as dez anos no
máximo os homens têm esse direito a 30
anos mas
ainda é uma certa forma inútil porque os
homens não visitam suas mulheres do
casci não é essas fibras que a gente vê
no domingo nas nas penitenciárias são
para as mulheres visitarem os seus
homens não existe essa fila nas prisões
femininas
outro tema que eu coloquei paralelo é a
prisão do craque que hoje se fala com
uma naturalidade das mães do craque que
já é uma forma preconceituosa de taxar
uma mãe né
a mulher que estava no crac o cidadão
que está no craque a vítima de um
problema de saúde pública gravíssima no
brasil é confundido com essa questão da
criminalidade é confundido com uma
situação e também de uma certa uma certa
não de uma invisibilidade que a gente
provoca nela quando nós olhamos à genoux
são os que até chama as pessoas diz um
bis no sumbe não existe então essa
pessoa não existe para nós a situação de
dois milhões de mais de 2 milhões de
usuários de crack no brasil são paulo
teria mais ou menos 400 mil usuários 20%
mulheres
essa pesquisa avaliou entrevistou e
verificou que de 27 9% mulheres 10 já
tinha tido gravidez no meio do uso do
crack
obviamente não 10 por cento admite não
todas tiveram a a gravidez a termo mas a
rotina do nosso trabalho na vara da
infância na cidade de são paulo é a
diária de abandono de bebês nos
hospitais pelas mães sob a uso sob o
efeito da droga com todas as
consequências que dá pra criança e dá
pra mãe a uma grande pedra de vínculos
familiares das mulheres que estão nas
ruas há um assédio imenso do tráfico
traficantes de crianças vivem entre as
mulheres guerreiras reduzindo-as para
que não têm os filhos dos hospitais
porque é uma forma também do controle do
estado ea o acolhimento também desse
bebê e quase sempre nós não localizamos
a família dessa mulher porque ela está
com as laços familiares estão rompidos
que não se encontra a família ou a
família já cuida de cinco seis filhos
dela não é mais rico nenhum e essa
criança tem que seguir o destino da da
adoção para terminar
eu lembro que essa criança temos aí em
contrapartida a esse direito das mães
que nós temos que garantir nós temos que
observar e cuidar o direito das crianças
antes da constituição a criança era
simplesmente objeto de uma política em
situação irregular
a criança incomodava o estado porque o
ela era delinqüente ou ela aparecia como
aquele abandonado e colocar vamos todos
juntos dentro de um local chamado febem
e não distinguimos esses direitos das
crianças como é k há uma mudança de
ruptura a criança passa a ser sujeito de
direito ea política então adotada até
agora é a política da proteção integral
que a própria palavra já diz por si
mesma e temos então a criança como
sujeito de direito que é um grande
trabalho do estado
o estado tem que desenvolver políticas
públicas de modo a garantir uma gama de
direitos que toda criança tem direito de
nascer de viver e crescer como brincar
ter saúde escola diversão e arte e o
direito à convivência familiar e é nesse
momento da garantia do direito à
convivência familiar e nós temos um
conflito com o direito da mãe de ser mãe
a despeito de ser presa então é uma
grande escolha triste e dolorosa que é
feita muitas vezes em deixar de lado
direito dessa mãe parece que é isso que
até que o estado faz ignora o direito da
mãe
prevalece o direito da criança não que
não mereça cuidar do direito da criança
mas veja que conflito é esse ea mãe uma
vez presa é desrespeitada é não não não
não significa dá ou não dignificar cada
um na sua qualidade de mulher enquanto
mãe é um grande dilema o estado
brasileiro não sabe resolver isso não
consegue resolver isso é muito precária
situação e acho importante trazer esse
tema porque nós mulheres é às vezes nós
mesmos damos um olhar de discriminação
para essa mulher está atrás das grades
nós não conhecemos o que geralmente é
pobre ea negra
muito obrigada